a pesar de estar vacunado desde febrero
con la vacuna rusa sputnik v el
presidente de rusia ha tenido que
ponerse en cuarentena tras detectarse
varios casos positivos de coronavirus en
su entorno cercano el portavoz del
presidente putin ha recalcado que el
aislamiento no afecta directamente al
trabajo del presidente ruso ya que
continuará sus actividades de manera
telemática la noticia del confinamiento
se ha sabido horas después de verse
putin con el líder sirio bashar assad y
a pocos días además la recta final de
las elecciones legislativas rusas la
visita del presidente sirio no estaba
anunciada y al parecer se celebró el
lunes aunque fue divulgada casi 24 horas
después ambos se vieron las caras sin
mascarillas como le gusta hacer a
vladimir putin el presidente ruso
también habló el lunes sin mascarillas
con los atletas paralímpicos y también
allí apuntó la posibilidad de hacer una
cuarentena también estuvo en la región
de nizhni nóvgorod observando las
maniobras capaz 2021 ha sido después a
su vuelta a moscú cuando el crimen ha
anunciado el confinamiento de vladimir
putin